and I'm here to talk a less funny
subject I'm here to talk about anxiety
and I'm here to tell you my story
so one time I was at a doctor's
appointment one of those you go like
every year to do a checkup and while I
was doing the normal questions and if
you ran with somebody are you doing
exercise she asked me can I measure your
blood pressure and I said yes why not
and once you did the exam I started to
feel like this anxious feeling you know
and I didn't know why that was happening
really and then at the end it revealed
that I had high blood pressure and for a
young person like me it's not normal so
she started to ask plenty of questions
that my answer was quite
um I don't know I don't think so but I
remember not to remember I told her that
I had anxiety
and she looked at me like you have
anxiety for
and I was like four and I made this
mental list these five things I could
remember at the top of my mind inflation
we're on Ukraine not knowing if my human
rights will be respected in the next 10
years not knowing if I'll ever be able
to afford a house not not knowing if
there I'll have a livable planet by the
time I'm 30. and this was just like five
seconds
but what I really told her was like I
don't know it happens it's a thing
and with this I don't mean to say like
I'm a mental health expert I'm just a
host to anxiety like many people around
the world and that it happens in for in
different reasons and has different
responses and today I meant to share my
history with it and this was just one
story of of many another one story is
one time I work in the youth field and I
work a lot with Erasmus projects and
that means that sometimes you have to
meet other partners to share to talk
about projects and we were in that part
you know when everybody introduced
themselves around the table and I was
the last one so I got to hear everybody
there are the big curriculum and I was
just a new guy you know the first month
where you have nothing to say really and
I just felt you know that imposter
syndrome when you feel like everybody's
better than you you have nothing to add
why am I here I just want to go home and
feeling the anxiety just creeping in and
this is one of those moments where you
realize that insecurities are a prime
source for anxiety why couldn't I be as
good as them I was just new
along the time anxiety came in different
forms and I have to backtrack a bit on
this for example socializing meeting new
people for me was always a challenge
until to this day because as a child
when you start to experience the world
you start to face also its ugly side
and many times as a kid I felt that
people would look weird at me and I
would start to look at myself and think
maybe it's the color of my skin or maybe
it's the way you know I express myself
maybe it's not too masculine
and that made me feel like I had to go
inside that I had I couldn't be out in
the world as I wanted to be
and so for many years I struggled in
silence
complete silence and that meant that I
was just accumulating in this safe space
me pain trauma and keeping everything
and everyone out
then unfortunately we had the pandemic I
think we still all remember that right
yeah that was a tough time I guess for
everybody and that meant for me
especially that I had no distractions
so anxiety caused me up all alone at
last
and that meant that I had to sit with it
and sitting with it meant I just was on
a Down Road spiral of just me not be
able to sleep
not being able actually to eat not being
able to dream and bear with me the dream
part is what led me to my breaking point
to feeling like I couldn't handle it
anymore and to ask for help
I think was one of the bravest things I
did in my short life is to ask for help
because I had nothing nothing else was
possible at that moment
so one morning I woke up I turned to my
mother after not sleeping a whole night
you know those anxiety nights where your
mind just go
and I told her I can't do this anymore I
need help and help meant therapy
and therapy is something that we don't
talk about but for me it was a savior
moment or a delight moment if you want
in therapy I had time to really go back
on these episodes and to really
understand that okay I'm a human being I
don't actually control anything I just
have to learn to deal with it but I
didn't say it yes immediately
you can imagine it took time for me to
actually understand this
also another thing for me vulnerability
is still like a hard thing and back then
was the hardest like how am I supposed
to be vulnerable when we live in the
world of pretense right
and that is still something that I'm
still working through and I invite you
all to work through really
but in therapy I also had to develop
strategies because guess what anxiety
doesn't go away with a few sessions
the life life still goes on and stuff
life will trigger you a lot
so I had to come up with five strategies
these are my strategies my responses
don't take it as like the only thing you
could do it's just my story one I try to
understand why I'm anxious and this
means that I try to root out in my mind
what is going on where is this coming
from and when I find it I'm like ah not
a big deal after all I can actually move
on but it takes time in braveness the
second one is self-love this one is like
it's a journey I'm still going through
it probably until the day I die I'll
have plenty to say but you have to
understand that it's hard for everybody
to love themselves and nobody really
teaches that even though like we all
experience love
but as a black and a person that is also
queer it's double the task because it's
something that it's not let's say accept
it or interest or talked about so that
takes an extra mile to do but it's
important because it makes you more
comfortable with yourself and it helps
with your anxiety because you're just
not fighting yourself anymore
my third one is the one that I'm like
talking to others like I love
communicating that's why I'm here but
I'm not a person say I am struggling to
take guys let's talk about it no and I
had to learn that in therapy to be able
to say today I'm not feeling well I need
my space I don't want to talk to anybody
really I just want to go and block
and this is important because sometimes
when we share that we are not okay
we'll find out that other people are
going through the same and this makes us
have deeper connections and not to feel
so alone because anxiety makes you
believe that you are alone which is not
true at all
another one for me is what we think
isn't a fact and bear with me we all are
liking what we think is what's gonna
happen not really we have to live to
actually figure it out what's going to
happen really try everything you want to
do even though anxiety is going to tell
you if maybe you're gonna die you're
gonna have a heart attack you're gonna
be stupid well that's a possibility but
that doesn't mean it's what's going to
happen and the last one is long walks
like I like to walk I like like walk I'm
walking backwards but I like to walk
somewhere
I like to walk without destination and
because I live in Lisbon I can go to the
afford to go to the beach and just you
know enjoy it really
and this is helpful why because when you
are walking your mind is busy with
something else besides your anxiety it
breaks down because you know obstacles
uh people everything is going on besides
it and your body understands there's
more going on
but I'm standing here not like a person
that is perfect imagine as I said life
is still going on when you're in therapy
when you have anxiety for example when
my grandmother died it was maybe one of
the hardest spirits of my life tragic
really when you have to deal with such
unbearable pain and I felt at the time
that was a time where anxiety was going
to regain its power over me because it
was a tragic moment a moment that I
didn't control
but it didn't because I had these
strategies and I had a different mindset
that helped me push through even though
I was through unbearable pain
but guys bear with me I'm not sitting
here as
normal normal whatever that means now
I'm totally broken but I'm not empty
this means that I still struggle and
I'll forever struggle but it's not like
before
you know that's what makes the
difference now I know that I have to
continue to do the things that I care
about even though that's going to give
me anxiety because believe me because we
care we are going to be anxious about it
there's different levels of anxiety to
be for example I care about this talk
and I was anxious sitting there but I
still I'm still here making it you know
it's still possible to make things
happen
it might not be perfect but you did it
because what anxiety really tries is to
refrain you from having anything besides
it
if you think about your anxiety moments
it's just there you don't have anything
you're stuck in yourself so go out live
really live boldly and be kind to
yourself and to others thank you
[Applause]